[Music]
hello YouTube just love us in my France
this is guns in here
welcome to the 44th episode of dirty
chest tricks in this episode I am going
to show you some of the wonderful tricks
and traps exists in the four Knights
variation from the white prospective the
opening arises after the falling model E
4 E Phi Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
instead of playing Bishop to c4 or
Bishop to b5 in my last dirty chess
trick video I have recommended this
tricky move Knight to c3 and as you can
see I have highlighted in the raid
arrows all these options are covered in
that video so if you haven't check it
out I strongly recommend you to go and
watch that video before proceed further
in this lecture we are going to
concentrate on one of the most accurate
response by black namely Knight to f6
so as the name suggests we have four
knights on the board and here white has
few options if you are a squash player
then you can continue with d4 and after
II kept his d4 and Knight captures d4 we
directly transpose into the squads game
except there is one difference that we
have force black to play the move Knight
to f6 which is benefit if you are
prepared very well apart from Knight
captures d4 there is yet another
aggressive move our white namely knight
to defy known as Belgrade gambit where
white
sacrifice second pawn to get tremendous
attacking position
however in this video I am going to
propose the third tricky option Bishop
to b5
so finally we transpose into the one of
the tricky line of royal or pears and
once again black has to play some
accurate response kindly note that if
your opponent here continued with either
the move Bishop to e7 or the moon d6
then it is going to be transposed the
line which we have already look at it in
my last episode let's say Bishop to e7
then we'll castle on the Kings side
threatening Bishop capture c6 and Knight
captures ePHI so black pretty much has
to defend this pawn with the move d6 and
after that we'll play this forcing
sequence d4 he captures d4 Knight
captures D for attacking the knight
Bishop to d7 Bishop captures c6 if
Bishop captures c6 then Knight to f4 is
a very strong reply so by force black
has to take with the b-pawn afterwards
we will play this amazing move Bishop
grave for the whole point is after black
castle on the Kings side we have this
lethal blow yup it's ePHI and after D
captures e5 Bishop captures ePHI Bishop
to d6 and the move Bishop to g3 at the
end of the whole sequence we managed to
give blacks some horrible spawn
structure on the Queen side which are
more than enough to create winning
advantage over the practical board
the second option I want to consider is
Bishop to c5 which surprisingly more
often I am facing on the internet and
people who don't know the theory they
will routinely turn out this move
thinking that this is just yet another
royal opus or the Italian game but here
it is outright mistake as in all the
lines white get tremendous attacking
initiative
to mention there are also some
high-profile tricks and traps after
Bishop to c5 White shoot castle on the
kingside and now black has two options
the first option d6 looks more obvious
as what is threatening the move Bishop
captures c6 and Knight captures ePHI but
after this move by force white get of
winning gauge before I move on I like
you to pause this video and find out
what is wrong with this natural setup by
black well I have won many games in this
line as the sequence is pretty much
forced white play the move d4 attacking
two spots
so black responds his force black has to
capture on d4 afterwards white will
continue with Knight capped is d4
attacking twice on c6 Knight if black
give up the bishop pair then longer and
he's going to suffer so natural response
is Bishop to d7 defending on c6 after
that we will continue with Knight to f5
threatening Knight captures g7 check and
here it doesn't matter whether black
continue with Castle or capture on fi
the most frequent response is black
eliminate this dangerous looking night
with Bishop captures fi pawn captures fi
and now in the view of rook to even
check black is forced to castle on the
Kings side afterwards sting in the tail
Bishop to g5 and you can already see
Knight to defy or night 24 is coming up
and there is no way black and stop fight
to destroy
King side bone structure and open up his
King recently I have won a very quick
game against 1800 and you can see that
game live in my second blade session
so if your opponent doesn't play careful
move from here onwards the game can be
finished very quickly however the story
doesn't end here because after the
accurate response by black such as at
six
Bishop to h4 and now Knight to d4 which
at first sight looks very cool right
well yes indeed
except here I have introduced my novelty
namely Knight to d5 ball ah-ha-ha-ha so
we are sacrificing the whole bishop and
the same time hitting on AB six black
has two good choices
obviously he cannot take on f5 which is
pretty bad the simple reason is after
Bishop captures f6g captures f6 and the
move Queen to h5 no matter however black
wriggles the game can be finished very
quickly
for example Queen to see it looks a
logical reply saving the night but here
white has this lethal reply by ship to
d7 and that Knight is a corner so let's
see what's the whole point of
sacrificing a piece after Knight
captures be fine well white's
idea is very cruel he wants to first of
all play a for hitting the night this
night has only one place to go
Knight to d4 and now wide reveal his
nasty idea Bishop captures f6g kept his
f6
destroying black pawn structure on
King's side and follow up with this
wonderful blow before so as you can see
by force white is getting a piece back
and even after one of the base reply by
black such as c6 counter-attacking of a
knight white can go with this forcing
sequence pawn cap to see fie
one captors defy Queen kept his d4 pawn
captures c5 and Queen kept a c5 after
the whole transaction even though we
have a material balance situation it is
only black who is going to suffer for
the rest of the game so this is one of
the wonderful forcing trick exists in
Bishop to c5 line which can provide you
lots of point especially in the
tournament practice instead of d6 black
and also Castle at this point but this
leads to the formula territory and if
you have seen my last video you already
know it yup it's deciding blow Knight
captures ePHI the whole point is we are
destroying black centre and after the
moon default we are regaining our piece
back this line has been played few times
at GM level and let me show you few
moves how white can continue as after
Bishop to d6 you should not capture
Aoife immediately but rather continue
with f4 and not only in future white get
his piece back but you can see the space
white is gaining in the center of the
board which give him ample opportunity
to attack black on the Kings side I have
attached to model game in the PGN which
will give you a very good idea how to
play such a position okay now let's deal
with some of the main line of the four
Knights and the first move is Knight to
d4 named as chigorin gambit
so here black is offering the spawn in
return for Bishop pair and some attack
on the open E file and accordingly
Bishop to a4 and Bishop to c4 are the
most popular choice however
my suggestion is you should become
greedy and capture on ePHI which will
completely shock your opponent basically
after night to be far it's all about
preparation and after watching this
video you are going to learn one of my
secret dirty chance trick which you can
confidently apply into Naumann practice
first important point if black goes for
the moon night kept his beef I then
might get a very good position after
Knight captures beef I c6 Knight to c3
Queen to e7 Knight to f3 Knight kept us
efore and now the star mu castle on the
Kings side and you can only see black
has some severe problems on the e-file
and in fact I have attached a model game
in the PGN between Nigel short and
Lambie where black literally get crushed
after few moose so obviously Knight
captures B Phi is not a good choice by
black the modern main line continues
with Queen to e7 attacking on the night
why should continue with f4 defending
the knight and now black has to first
remove the bishop in order to play the
move d6 so he does so with Knight
captures B Phi Knight captures B Phi and
now the move d6 okay what has to move
the knight and
kindly note if Knight captors efore then
castle is a very good response so by
force black has to play Queen captures
efore hoping that white will play the
move Queen to e2 and the resulting
position is quite better for the black
but here comes surprise hing to f2 and
suddenly you can see the problem in the
black camp he has to be with the two
threads rook - even and night to c7
so by force we get him in the muddy
water where black needs to provide some
really careful moves first more is very
obvious like 2g4 check and confidently
enough we are going to continue with
King to g3 and even though a king looks
bit funny on g3 still our threats are
remaining hazardous I got this position
few times in my games and here black has
the only response Queen to g6 in one
game against 2008 opponent continuously
Queen to c6
which looks more natural in this
position attacking the knight as well as
defending on c7 but I'm afraid this is a
big time mistake as White has this
winning continuation quaint we to check
if King to d8 then black king is already
misplaced so black has to defend the
check with Bishop to e7 afterwards we
will pressurize this Bishop with rook to
even okay there's a maid threatened so
the only response is Queen to d7
defending on e7 but here the disaster
stuck on the black cam my opponent get
this rude shock there so it looks like
we have done the exchange sacrifice but
in fact it's not as after Queen captures
c7 we have this Intermezzo night to c7
check and after King to d8 and rook
captures a 7 black 2 pcs are hanging and
after the obvious continuation King
captures a 7 Knight captures eight white
clearly emerged with extra piece and
upon so that means here black has to
forcefully play the move Queen to g6
trying to get a discovered attack on the
White King
well accordingly right has the only
response night to H for attacking the
Queen and Black has two choices in this
position the first move Queen to h5
which I personally think is bit
inaccurate the simple reason is after
Knight captures c7 check King to the
edge
if white goes for the rook in the corner
then I think GFI is a very strong reply
so accordingly
White has to play an accurate move in
this position and that is h3 counter
attacking the knight well there is a
line here where black can play the move
Knight to f6 and then sacrifice the
Queen but I don't think so black can
find it over the board and even though
if we find it the resulting position is
quite balanced for the white and I have
attached a sample line in the PGN more
often you are going to see this move
King capture c7 which is very obvious
destroying the attacker but then white
will continue with H captures g4 and we
have a unique position where both the
Kings are misplaced but white emerge
with extra pawn and practice shows that
white has a very good winning ratio from
this position Queen to f6 and this
position is one of the best reply by
black which has a very cunning idea that
if you go ahead and play the move Knight
to c7 then Jafar has a very strong reply
well of course white is not going to
fall for Knight to c7 check but rather
he has to choose this very strong move
h3 attacking the knight and if the
knight retrieved the knight capture c7
is definitely on the card so accordingly
black has the only moon in this position
G Phi which actually threatening mate on
f4 something which white needs to
respond immediately here my
recommendation is what should continue
with Queen to e to check and if
black bloc the check with Bishop to e7
or move the King then F captures Jafar
is a strong reply so once again black
has to find the only response in this
position namely Knight to e5 and if your
opponent has not prepared well then I
doubt that he can find this more anyways
after Knight to e5 the mating thread
remains as it is so white has to defend
this with Knight to f3
once again renewing the two threats and
accordingly black responds his force he
has to capture on f4 if G captures f4
then I can play the King to h2 and it
turned out that white King is more safer
than the black King and on top of
everything big threats are looming on
the black camp I got this position
against a feed a master where he
continued with Queen to e7 which is more
logical in this position defending every
single thread and coming out as a pawn
up but this is just an illusion as white
can still go on and play the move
nightcap to c7 check ok black responds
his force black has to capture this and
now white get his piece back with d4 and
the whole point is sooner or later White
will get his piece as well as pawn back
with a great deal of interest let me
show you what I mean the game continued
with epics I captured on e5 my opponent
recaptured with the I pawn and now I get
my porn bag as well with fish are kept
safe for indeed there is a threat of
Knight captures ePHI so my opponent
defended with Bishop to d6 I continue
with route a - d'avin and black has to
be very careful at this position if we
routinely continue with Bishop to d7
then White has this little sacrifice of
captures d6 so accordingly my opponent
took the wise decision he Castle on the
Kings side
afterwards I simply continued with
pressurizing the black camp with Quinn
to d3 attacking on d6 he defended with
rook to the edge but when you operon
King is wide open like this this
sacrifice are bound to be happen in the
game and correctly enough I continue
with my captors if I F captures ePHI or
what else and now white give this check
which force King to go in the epsilon
square as if he continued with King to
h8 then rook Aptus d6 is office response
so accordingly here he decided to go
King to have seven but this doesn't help
him at all as after Bishop to g5
attacking the rook efore so for a moment
it looks like I made a blunder but
thankfully here white has this saving
resource ro captures d6 Queen captures
d6 Bishop captures th and black should
have exchanged the Queen we're in the
resulting position is slightly better
for the wide but my opponent become
greedy and capture on d8 which allow me
to finish the game very quickly with
rook to F in check King to e7 Queen Jack
King to e8 and after Queen to g8 King to
e7 and Quint Webb 7 check my opponent
simply resign as not only black is going
to lose his queen
but his King can hardly survive from
such a position the more often played
more in this position is Queen captures
f4 check which looks more natural but in
fact after King to f2 white is winning
on the spot we
have two threads and black cannot bury
both of them as king to d8 leads to the
move d4 and black is going to lose a
piece so that's not a good option for
black and that could response by a black
namely g4 doesn't work here because of
the following forcing sequence d4
attacking the Queen pawn captures f3
counter attacking the Queen Bishop
captures f4 pawn captures e to pawn
captures ePHI threatening Knight
captures c7 and it doesn't matter
wherever the King goes let's say King to
d7 defending on c7 we can pile up on the
d6 square with pawn captures d6 pawn
captures d6 look to even a6 Knight to c3
defy rook captures e 2 and after Bishop
to b7 and rook to d1 the d6 pawn is
doomed and on top of one point advantage
white pieces are extremely active so it
is obvious that after Knight captures
ePHI black has to no lot of theoretical
moves and even if he knows that the
resulting position is quite favorable to
the white camp last but not least let's
look at one of the most popular choice
by black namely Bishop to b4 where here
we are going to follow the main line for
a while castle on the Kings side
castle on the Kings side D 3 d6 and now
our familiar territory yup Bishop to g5
threatening Knight to d5 here two moves
has been tried if your opponent
continues with Bishop captures C 3
followed by Queen to e7 then I have
attached a model game of cioppino in the
PGN which will give you a very good idea
how to play such a position for
advantage
however I like to show you one important
trick in the Moon Knight to e7 which is
in fact the second best choice by the
black here by far
Knight to h4 is the most popular choice
however I am going to propose a very
tricky move in this position namely
given up the bishop pair with Bishop
captures f6g capture Sept 6 open up the
black King and followed up with Knight
wedge 4
so as you can see I have highlighted by
the arrows very simple an effective plan
of campaign by white which gives him a
very attacking chances on black king
just relisted my point I like to show
your miniature between two 2388 opponent
where black continues with obvious moves
and still find himself at the losing
iron in a very short order
c6 happen on the board white plays
Bishop to e4 and now Knight to g6 so
this is the whole point of playing
Knight to e7 black and defend his King
side with this Knight and later on push
forward with a final four okay white
continue with Knight to f5 capturing the
important half v square and seeing white
attack looming black try to exchange
some pieces with Bishop capture c3 be
capture c3 Bishop captures a fire and
now he captures f5 attacking the knight
Knight to e7 attacking the pawn Queen to
h5 defending and now black plays the
obvious move Queen to d7 attacking twice
on f5 well at first sight it looks like
that pawn is a goner right but not white
has this practical resource f4 which
sells the pond in a broad daylight well
seeing black cannot do anything about
that pawn black switches attention on
the c3 pawn with Knight to d5
but I think this is a great inaccuracy
as the plant which I have mentioned
earlier comes into the picture
immediately with F captures 'if i d
captures ePHI and the MU rook to f3 well
there's a general saying that if you can
block you up on an F pawn then your King
side attack will roll down and here
black has not one but two air pawns
well black realized the danger in this
position and he continued with Knight to
f4 attacking the Queen
but after Queen to at six I think the
game is about to or as rook to g3 is a
portent threat and black played only few
moves to keep himself alive in the game
with Queen captures fi so in case of
rook to g3 Knight to g6 is a strong
reply but what he missed is after rook
to g3
Knight to g6 White has another look in
the picture which completely slider with
the Queen and once she goes away white
attack will literally crash on the black
head with rook to f6 there are many ways
a fight can finish black off one of the
easiest ways to play the move Bishop to
b3 and then something captured on g6 and
second white option is rook to West he
ends create some problem on the H and
the G file so I guess this is a model
demonstration how one can bust Knight to
e7 line from the black that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and learn this to Knights
tricky line against one of the most
solid option by black I am playing this
line from last one year or so and the
good point I found about them is they
are lot of tricky and not many of your
opponent of finding the right more order
well best of luck for trying out in your
own game and feel free to like subscribe
and
comment on this video I will meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care